hey guys today's date is March 24 2020 I
want you to know that because all the
information I'm sharing makes sense
up until this date the situation is
evolving rapidly so know that things do
change that being said one of my main
goals on this channel is to beat up on
misinformation and I've done a doctor
fact checks media video already you love
that now I'm doing a doctor fact checks
politicians because I've seen some
politicians make statements that are at
best negligent and at times purposefully
inaccurate but before we start I want to
make a comment about ending social
distancing this week the story has moved
to how long should we be doing this
social distancing is it worth the
economic impact of closing of small
businesses people losing their jobs the
stock market taking a tumble and it's
actually a good question we should be
asking it and doctors like myself should
really be providing answers in a time of
unknowns I just watched a panel on Fox
News of President Trump vice president
pence a few others talking about this
exact issue President Trump made a
statement where he says we should be
getting back to work around April 12th
which is Easter time now many people are
asking is that the wise move to do we
don't know we don't know if that's the
right move to do yet we need to conduct
more tests we need to get doctors on the
front lines their equipment that we need
to treat patients and we need to see
what's happening how the situation is
evolving making any kind of prediction
now for April 12th is a full-on guess we
don't have all the numbers we don't know
how the situation is gonna evolve so I
think we need to pump the brakes a
little bit at this very moment the
reason why I say the economic losses are
still worth it because of the worry of
run on hospitals this isn't a
theoretical problem Italy's having it
right now and if we have it here in the
United States people are gonna suffer
not just those who are over the age of
70 everyone's gonna pay a toll for this
what I'd like to see happen over the
next few weeks hospitals get more
prepared we transform civilian buildings
like Jacob Javits Center right around
the corner hotel rooms in order to act
as impromptu hospitals we get personal
protective equipment and ventilators to
hospitals see how many people are sick
with property
testing kits and only once we have all
this in place in the next two weeks can
we then start talking about estimates
right now no place for it during this
Fox News White House panel they had
three doctors on dr. sapphire dr. Siegel
and dr. oz each asking a question of
vice president Pence and president Trump
unfortunately none of them asked if our
politicians are afraid of a run on
hospitals the simple question remains
what do we do and how do we prepare for
when millions of people simultaneously
catch this novel coronavirus and even if
1% need ventilator support which is
probably more than that how can we
manage with not enough equipment how do
we manage with not enough protection
where health providers are gonna get
sick and they have to stay home we need
to think about us on the front lines and
really get president Trump pence and
everyone in the political sphere to
think about us and how we need to manage
the situation
all right let's fact check some
politicians making statements about the
novel coronavirus that may not be
accurate and some that are really
dangerous the World Health Organization
offered offered two testing kits that
they have available and to give it to us
now we refuse them we're testing kits
available that were perfectly fine yes
however these tests are largely reserved
for low-income countries that don't have
the testing capacity don't have the
ability to make their own tests in fact
many countries we're making their own
tests and not taking them because they
have the economy to do so how would it
look if an economic superpower like the
u.s. started claiming these kids for
themselves just pretty bad I think what
really slowed down our response time was
that the initial test the CDC sent out
were faulty and second it took forever
to commercialize these tests for private
labs to do this sort of testing now that
that's happening where bio reference lab
core are able to do them we can get more
tests done we have a drug called Laura
Quinn derivation would be
hydroxychloroquine we think it has a
very serious very good impact on what
we're talking about with respect to the
virus so you'll take a look at that and
you can coordinate with us but I think
to me that's a game changer first and
foremost
it's not a game-changer yet yet we like
to be optimistic in the medical
community but first and foremost we have
to be healthy skeptics that does not
mean we disbelieve everything we hear it
means that we have to take everything
with a grain of salt
especially basing it on limited research
the research that we have presented thus
far is mainly anecdotal research meaning
stories or certain compassionate uses
where we're just using that medication
and an experimental form in fact there
was a recent research study that came
out combining hydroxychloroquine this
anti malaria medication with
azithromycin which is an antibiotic
medication and it found that it
decreased the amount of the virus that's
present in the nasopharyngeal swabs that
we use to test for it now this is a very
small study it wasn't randomized the
people that got both drugs were only six
that's a very small number so until we
do a proper clinical trial and
understand exactly what it means to have
less virus in your nose because what
good is it if you have less virus in
your nose but you're still showing
horrible symptoms and still having the
same outcomes we need more info that's
what I'm saying we need to do more
research before we start calling it a
miracle drug a game-changer because what
happens people start taking it
unnecessarily and get side effects
all medications have side effects in
fact there was a couple that ended up
taking some kind of form of chloroquine
I think it was to clean their aquarium
or fish tank and ended up dying well the
husband died and now the wife is in an
intensive care unit so we need to be
very careful with our language here
another issue that I'm sure the
president didn't think about when he
made these statements now it's nearly
impossible for my patients who have been
taking hydroxychloroquine brand-name
Plaquenil for lupus or different types
of autoimmune conditions to get it
because of this rush on pharmacies
because people think it cures or treats
the novel coronavirus I think at a time
like this we have to look to the major
organizations to give us guidance doctor
foul Qi cleared up some of the
fact-checking there the FDA came out and
said they have not FDA approved
hydroxychloroquine to be a treatment are
we using it and some compassionate use
cases yes but we have to understand this
is
experimentation use only at this time
this disease could take your life but
that's not the scariest thing to you
there's something that would be worse
than dying yeah and look I'm gonna do
everything I can to live but you know if
you said are you willing to take a
chance and you know if I get sick I'll
go and try to get better but if I don't
I don't and I'm not trying to think in
any kind of morbid way Tucker but I'm
just saying that that we got a choice
here and and we're gonna be in a total
collapse recession depression collapse
in our society if this goes on another
several months there won't be any jobs
to come back to for many people the
entire interview sets up a false
dichotomy we're ok putting at risk those
above the age of 70 or we have the
economic collapse of this country this
is a purely false dichotomy it's not
that simple
there are many choices to be made and
it's not about saying this is gonna take
nine months or six months or three
months or two weeks because we don't
know it's an evolving situation that we
constantly have to monitor and make
changes when appropriate now the reason
I bring up the false dichotomy is
because we need to understand that it's
not just about those over the age of
seven if we open the country back up too
early the risk isn't just to them it's
to all of us not only our 30 year olds
20 year olds 50 year olds still gonna
get sick some of them severely there's
still a death rate in those people but
it's gonna happen so quickly that
hospitals like my own like the ones in
York City are going to get overrun and
doctors are not going to be able to
provide care not only to coronavirus
patients but to everyone you're gonna be
a 20 year old involved in a car accident
those happen all the time guess what I
see yous full of Crona patients where
are you gonna go if you're diagnosed
with cancer you need an infusion we
don't have anymore IV supplies because
we're using them on the coronavirus
patients where are you gonna go this is
not just about those who are over the
age of 70 I encourage lieutenant
governor to come to New York City take a
look at the hospitals that are already
here overcrowded the ICUs are nearly
working at capacity we're going through
40 to 70 thousand and nine
five masks a day that's with the economy
shutdown
imagine we opened it up and everybody
gets sick at the same time who's gonna
take care of these people I have no idea
because I'll tell you exactly what
happens if we do that we're gonna run
out of equipment first and foremost
doctors are gonna be facing decisions on
who to intubate the 20 year old who has
no medical problems the 30 year old who
has two kids the 50 year old who has a
family but smokes or the 70 year old who
has many health problems but has been
paying into Social Security and Medicare
their entire lives how do you make that
decision healthcare providers are still
going to be there on the front lines
because that's what we do we're gonna
get sick we're gonna start losing our
lives we're gonna stop showing off to
showing up to work and who is going to
be there to take care of the patients
who need help that are not coronavirus
patients I don't have an answer to that
so it's not as simple as let's open up
the country to save jobs we all want
that we don't want the economy to
collapse as doctors in fact something
Trump said earlier on another press
conferences if doctors just had their
way they'd shut down the entire country
for a period of time yeah maybe in an
experiment form but not in real life we
don't want to destroy the economy we
want to make sure that we lose the least
amount of lives possible we keep
hospitals up and running and we're able
to take care as many people while
maintaining a proper economy now can we
open up the country in a few weeks time
it's very possible but we need to wait
we need to get more testing kits done we
need to get providers the protection we
need on the frontlines and then make
evaluations as they come there's no need
to go on national television and say
something dramatic that you're willing
to lay down your life for the novel
coronavirus to save the economy because
it's a false dichotomy and an inaccurate
statement
he's defunded Centers for Disease
Control's they've cut the funding for
the CDC the reality of the matter is
that neither of these statements are
true in 2019 Trump proposed a cut of one
point three six billion dollars to the
seat he proposed this cut Congress would
have let him have it
instead they increased the CDC budget by
two hundred sixty one point six million
dollars for 2020 Trump proposed cutting
the CDC budget by 750 million dollars
that
Congress wouldn't let him do it instead
they signed a 420 million increase to
the CDC budget so while yes
Trump has proposed cuts to the CDC he's
tried cutting their budget he's never
tried to fully defund it and he's never
successfully cut the budget in fact over
the last two years that budget has gone
up please politicians when you're making
statements like this tell the full story
the nasal passages passages and the
nasal membranes or the coolest part of
the body that's why the virus tends to
go there until it then becomes healthy
enough to go into the lungs
this is sounds really goofy and it did
to me too but it works once the
temperature reaches 136 degrees
Fahrenheit the virus falls apart and
just the minutes disintegrates okay and
I said well how would you get the
temperature up to 132 degrees the answer
was you use a blow dryer because it's
capable of doing that so you hold a blow
dryer in front of your face and you
inhale with your nose and it kills all
the viruses in your nose okay this is
the prime example of misinformation
where it sounds like something's totally
feasible and reasonable to do to protect
yourself from the novel coronavirus
that has zero scientific backing and it
has a hundred percent potential to harm
you so if you're gonna have a blow dryer
first of all most blow dryers I just
looked this up don't get nearly as hot
as 140 degrees Fahrenheit they get
somewhere around 110 120 some of the
higher end ones can but even if they do
they're gonna burn you what this County
Council member is suggesting is that we
blow-dry our noses which will a dry up
our nasal mucus membranes make us more
susceptible to a virus by causing cracks
in the skin - it's gonna burn our faces
especially for doing this in the elderly
population that have more sensitive skin
so no 140 degrees directly to the face
will cause first-degree burns please do
not do this just to update you on the
n95 mask situation in my last video i
donated 27,000 dollars worth of masks it
was a tough time as you probably have
seen people have reached out and some
people have been trying to make a dollar
on me by
selling me more masks not doing that
anymore but then there's many of you
that have offered donations and I want
to thank you for those who have one of
the biggest donations thus far has been
copper compression comm they donated
18,000 reusable ke n95 masks these are
gonna make a world of a difference to us
on the front lines huge thank you to
them I'm dropping their link down below
check out their other products that are
copper infused I've put together
playlist for you of some of my favorite
videos here and if you haven't seen me
haggle and negotiate for life-saving
equipment for the tune of $50,000 click
here while staying happy and healthy
[Music]